Punch him right in his face.
Hello.
Hey, hi there, can you let me in?
How bout you let me in.
Please, I won't hurt you.
Maybe I am turning into the monster here.
Why do I always ruin everything?
I just want this to be a nice, normal
operation with.
Kill it with fire.
>> All right you bastard kiddies.
I've had it up to here with you guys.
[NOISE]
>> Oooh.
Hi.
I'm an SCP now.
S-C-P.
M-A-R-K-I-P-L-I-E-R.
The most lethal SCP around.
[SOUND].
I'm not actually lethal, I just like to
pop out of walls and go [SOUND].
Ah!
I almost walked right into that.
[SOUND].
Well, I'm just the biggest idiot that ever
existed in the entire world.
I'm so stupid.
I never even bothered to try and jump.
What kind of moron am I?
To my one million fans, thank you.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Until you detect something moving in
front of the light.
Casting a shadow over you, you blink.
Beginning to turn.